début des années 60 en pleine guerre
d'algérie la france est touchée par une
série d'attentats à la manoeuvre lowell
l'organisation de l'armée secrète ce
groupes proches de l'extrême droite
lutte pour le maintien de l'algérie
française la liste des explosions salon
low as contraindre appelle la criminelle
folie de ces méthodes aveugle qui heurte
toutes les consciences contre ces
attentats 20000 à 30000 personnes
manifestent à paris une manifestation
non autorisée c'était le 8 février 1962
il y à 60 ans sur ces images la police
réprime violemment le cortège des
personnes se retrouvent acculés piétiné
à l'entrée du métro charonne bilan neuf
morts roger frey alors ministre de
l'intérieur rejette la faute sur les
manifestants mais groupe organisé de
véritables émeutiers armés de manches de
pioche de boulons de morceaux de grille
de pavés d'outils divers
contacter le service d'ordre en
particulier boulevard marché rue de
charonne mise à part cette déclaration
après côté politique c'est silence radio
pas de commentaire il faut attendre le 8
février 1982 soit vingt ans plus tard
pour que la sphère soit une nouvelle
fois médiatisée de nombreuses
manifestations ont eu lieu aujourd'hui à
paris en souvenir de la tragédie du
métro charonne des syndicats et le parti
communiste sont venus commémorer
l'événement une plaquette aussi
installés dans le métro en souvenir des
victimes tout d'abord la cgt aux
militaires les neuf victimes de sharon a
rassemblé ses sympathisants samedi ici
même et ce matin au cimetière du père
lachaise aujourd'hui la cfdt la fen et
des syndicats d'enseignants se sont à
leur tour rendus sur le lieu des
affrontements
1982 toujours c'est aussi l'année des
premiers témoignages à la télé écouter
celui de marina vlady l'actrice était
présente à l'époque au moment des faits
j'ai eu la chance de peut-être en
écrasant des gens d'ailleurs je n'en
sais rien à me sortir de cette masqué
qui roulait j'ai couru j'ai sauté un
truc de kiss et de séparation et j'ai je
suis monté dans une rame et nous étions
deux il y avait un garçon
visiblement un garçon rigoureux aussi
comme quand je l'étais avant
mais on était faire et on plus respirer
on a failli vomir tellement j'avais peur
mais du côté de la classe politique
toujours rien aucune commémoration
jusqu'en 2002 cette année là bertrand
delanoë à leur maire de paris est venu
rendre hommage aux victimes c'est une
première
dépôt de gerbes salut au drapeau
quarante ans plus tard leur nom et était
fleurie honoré à l'appel de la cgt et en
présence du maire de paris bertrand
delanoë en 2007 la place du 8 février
1962 et inaugurée par le maire de paris
aujourd'hui soixante ans après les faits
la france n'a pas admis sa
responsabilité dans cette affaire
plusieurs syndicats et des militants
demandent à ce que le 8 février 1962
soit considérée comme un crime d'état
[Musique]